After several days of camping
and long-distance bicycle
riding, you decide to
ride straight home riding
at a constant rate.
After 2 hours of riding, you
are 10 kilometers from home.
And after 4 hours of riding,
you are 5 kilometers from home.
Once you begin to ride
home, in how many hours
will you finish your bike
ride and arrive at home?
This last sentence is
a little bit redundant.
It really should say,
what was your total length
of your bike ride home?
But let's just think about
the data that they gave us.
So let's just think
about on one column,
let's put how long
you've been riding.
So time.
Time riding.
And then in this column let's
put the distance from home.
So they tell us
that after 2 hours,
and the time is in
hours, after 2 hours
we are 10 kilometers from home.
And after 4 hours, we are
5 kilometers from home.
And we are going home
at a constant rate.
So let's think about
what this rate is.
When our time
increased by 2 hours,
our distance decreased by 5.
So if our time increased
by another 2 hours,
so now 6 hours have gone
by, then our distance
will have decreased
by 5 again, and we
are 0 kilometers from home.
So we've answered our question.
Once you begin to ride
home, in how many hours
will you finish your bike
ride and arrive home?
Well, it'll take you
a total of 6 hours.
Now, I'm going to ask
ourselves another question
that they didn't ask us here.
Which is, how far away was I
when I started riding home?
Well, we could back
things up a little bit.
Actually, let me copy
and paste all of this.
And move it down.
So let me cut, let me paste
this all down a little bit,
so we have some extra space.
And let me draw a
little white line here.
And then finally, let me erase
this business right over here.
And so we could think
of it the other way.
Where were we at time 0?
So time 0, that was 2
hours before this point
right over here.
So here we are
subtracting 2 hours.
So instead of subtracting
5, we will add 5.
They're going to
have opposite signs.
So we were 15 kilometers away.
Another way that you
could think about this
is we started 15 kilometers
away, 2 hours goes by
and our distance has
decreased 5 kilometers.
So let's actually
graph this just
to visualize things
in graphical form.
So let's say that
this is our time axis,
actually our distance axis.
Distance in this case
is a function of time,
so the convention is to plot
that on the vertical axis.
And then let's put time
on the horizontal axis.
So that is time
right over there.
So when time equals 0 our
distance is 15 kilometers.
This is 5, 10, 15.
So when time is equal to 0,
distance is 15 kilometers.
That's this point
right over here.
And then when time
is equal to 6,
our distance is 0 kilometers.
So it's not perfectly--
so let's say
that this is 1 hour, 2 hours, 3
hours, 4 hours, 5 hours, and 6
hours, obviously, it should
be drawn a little bit neater
than that.
Let's do it this way.
Let's call this
2, 4, and 6 hours.
Obviously, not the
same scales for
the vertical and
horizontal axes.
But this last point right over
here when time is 6 hours,
our distance from
home is 0 kilometers.
So that's that point there.
And we're traveling
at a constant rate.
So our line will look like this.
Now one question you might
ask yourselves, well,
can we quantify this
rate, or how would
this rate relate to the
inclination of this line?
Well remember, the
inclination of this line
is defined as slope,
and that's the rate
of change of our vertical
axis to our horizontal axis.
So the slope of this line
is equal to the change
in our vertical axis.
This triangle is the
Greek letter delta,
shorthand for change in.
Change in our vertical
axis with respect
to a change in our
horizontal axis.
So in our horizontal
axis, we already
see when we have a change
of 2 in our horizontal axis,
and we saw that with
the first two points,
when we went from
2 comma 10, that
was this point right
over here, to 4 comma
5, what was our change in time?
Well, our change in time
was we went from 2 to 4.
So I could do it
right over here.
So our change in
time was equal to 2.
And what was our
change in distance?
Well our change in distance,
we went from 10 to 5.
So our change in distance
was equal to negative 5.
It went down when
our time increased.
So it's negative 5.
So the slope of this
line is negative 5/2.
We started at time
0 at 15 kilometers,
so actually we could express
the equation for this line.
We could write that
distance-- and we could even
write it as distance as a
function of time like that,
or we could just write
distance-- is equal to,
we started at 15
kilometers, and then
we decreased our distance
from there as time increases.
So it's 15 plus
negative 5/2 times time,
or we could say
minus 5/2 times time.
So we didn't have
to do all of this.
We could have just reasoned
through it with the table
that we did really
in the first minute,
but it is nice to
just think about this
in all the different ways.